for your information
not only am i going to show you up today
i've also prepared some biblical trash
talk
what is he talking about he stayed up
all night studying
why to beat you at bible trivia just
like the prophets of mercy beat the
priestly called its emphasis on ritual
purity
was that the trash talk was the key as
the tax collector was nicodemus a
pharisee
just hit him okay campers
bible trivia time for a noah's ark rain
poncho what was peter's original name
sheldon peter's original name was simon
correct
you didn't know that one did you yes i
did he was also known as cephus
then why didn't you raise your hand
cause i don't care
next question for a john the baptist
pencil topper
where did jesus perform his first
miracle
sheldon a wedding correct
aren't you even going to try no
why won't you compete with me because
it's fun watching you get upset what's
fun about it
everything
paige a sprig of my hair is askew
upsetting isn't it
no but it's going a different direction
from all the other hairs
so you think it's fun irritating me
i'm giving you a taste of your own
medicine huh look how close this push
pin is to this balloon
it could pop at any moment i bet that
drives you quickly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello what now what now
what are you doing what are you doing
i'm just gonna repeat everything are you
just gonna repeat everything i say
i sheldon q i sheldon cooper except
jesus christ is my lord and since jesus
christ
go get me a beer woman what it
infuriates my mom when my dad says it
sheldon stop you can't upset me why not
because there are things in my life that
are way worse than anything that you can
come up with
you mean your parents splitting up
obviously
i think i know how to irritate you i bet
you think the divorce is all your fault
and now your family is torn apart
forever
[Music]
did i do it did i get under your skin
i can still hear the sound of her fist
hitting your face and your head bouncing
off the floor
that is enough it was like slack i said
enough amber donut holes
what a great day
[Music]
that night my brother turned a ratty old
van into his chariot of love
[Music]
the romance was in the air
oh hey mr boggs i'm just here to pick up
janna
you think you're taking my daughter out
in this no worries i'll have her home by
11.
oh i wouldn't open that
move
he's got a mini fridge
i thought about what you said i'm
returning the van good night
this is the kind of weather that makes
you want to stay home if you don't have
to go out today
[Music]
don't
[Music]
foreign